jour 10 de la mobilisation les artistes
intermittents et les précaires de la
culture n'en démordent pas ils réclament
toujours la réouverture des lieux de
spectacle le grand théâtre le théâtre
olympia deux tours ainsi que la halle
aux grains de blois sont désormais
partiellement occupée samedi dernier des
performances publiques ont d'ailleurs eu
lieu devant la halle aux grains de blois
et sur le parvis du centre dramatique
national de tours pour demander
notamment la prolongation de l'année
blanche pour les intermittents ambiance
côté tourangeau avec romain delville du
violon des lectures de la poésie de la
danse de l'improvisation 10 minutes
chacun chacune
les artistes lutte en jouant devant un
public
c'est le sens et l'essence de leur
métier aujourd'hui encore interdit
pourquoi on fait ce métier c'est
justement pour qu'il y ait ce lien ce
lien qu'on peut pas avoir avec une vidéo
youtube ce lien qui qui est l'opposé de
l'individualisme une vidéo youtube c'est
quelqu'un qui vient montrer son ego à la
face du monde et qu'ils s'en moquent de
savoir qui est en face on est ce que
ressentent les gens fassent le delight
et puis c'est tout sur un plateau de
théâtre ses différents coups sur une
scène de musique c'est différent on est
là pour avoir une interaction avec les
gens pas pour pas pour l'heure de donner
la becquée sur le parvis du théâtre
olympia c'est aussi l'avenir de la
profession qui défile avec beaucoup de
jeunes artistes en devenir
parmi eux certains occupants journée le
centre dramatique national de tours
depuis le 16 mars la génération covit de
la culture ne veut pas que la précarité
deviennent la norme la plus grande
inquiétude c'est comment est-ce que ça
va laisser le monde du spectacle
après tout ça avec ce quand on aura la
réouverture des lieux culturels
là on occupe mais on occupe en se
projetant aussi c'est à dire que oui on
veut la réouverture des lieux culturels
mais on veut aussi par exemple pas
sortir d'un master est juste avoir un
smic alors oui tout geste et
revendications pour la réouverture des
lieux culturels pour la prolongation de
l'année blanche des intermittents mais
le temps d'une journée les artistes ont
aussi donné une grande bouffée d'oxygène
sur le parvis du cnt